et là sous vos yeux ébahis apparaît un
alphaget alors nous on ne vous annonce
pas le retour de l'école de chasse à
Tours il s'agit en fait du nouveau
spectacle de Gaëlle Le Magicien sur
scène le loir-et-charien est aux côtés
de cet avion mythique employé encore
aujourd'hui par la patrouille de France
une prouesse que nous raconte Clémence
d'os qu'au contrôle en Sologne
voici
donc la viande
sur lequel on travaille depuis déjà un
moment un long moment et c'est cet avion
qui sera donc dans le spectacle parce
qu'en fait j'ai toujours été fan de
magie depuis mon plus jeune âge mais
aussi et surtout d'aéronautique 12
mètres de long 5 mètres de haut avec cet
Alpha Jet Gael briné a mis la barre très
haut pour son nouveau spectacle un
projet de longue haleine entre multiples
coups de fil et autorisation officielle
le ministère des armées voyant un moyen
de susciter des vocations à accepter de
lui prêter l'avion on a besoin de le
nettoyer parce qu'il y a plein
d'artifices il y a plein de les
éclairages aussi dessus ça crée de la
poussière donc on essaie de l'entretenir
un maximum voilà un Alpha Jet bichonné
puisque star d'un numéro unique au monde
l'illusionnistes blessois la présenter
en avant-première à Salon-de-Provence le
19 mai dernier un showcase privé en
présence des pilotes de la Patrouille de
France
un crash test couronné de succès
notamment grâce à l'aide de son équipe
une vingtaine de personnes jouant des
lumières depuis l'ombre en gros c'est
nous qui donnons on va dire l'image
visuelle en gros du spectacle donc la
direction en gros quelle couleur mais
quels effets en mai voilà qu'est-ce
qu'on doit éclairer qu'est-ce qu'on doit
pas éclairé quand on dévoile pas les
secrets que ça quelque chose comme de
joli visuellement mais voilà tout en
gardant le secret qu'on les voit pas les
tours de passe-passe par inadvertance
des secrets bien gardés pour entretenir
la magie de ce rêve d'enfant petit
Gaëlle se voyait pilote ou magicien il a
fini par faire d'une pierre deux coups
quand j'étais tout petit j'ai assisté
déjà une amyting aérienne j'allais dans
des simulateurs j'ai toujours trouvé ça
magique de voir un avion volé ça peut
paraître stupide mais depuis mon plus
jeune âge lorsque je voyais un avion ça
pouvait être un avion de chasse ou même
un avion de ligne je trouvais ça fou
dingue ce spectacle le plus personnel
s'envolera bientôt en tournée première
escale le 23 novembre prochain à la
scène musicale de Paris